hilfe wer hat mein brautkleid susanne
und maria aus neuss in nrw haben
momentan kein anderes thema mehr
seit über einem jahr planen die beiden
ihre traumhochzeit am 5 september jetzt
drei wochen vor dem stichtag der schock
die reinigung hat das 2800 euro kleid
verschlammt kein scherz erst zuhause
merkt susanne dass das gewaschene
abgeholte kleid nicht ihres ist bilder
aus der überwachungskamera zeigen auch
noch die verwechslung und trotzdem der
mann mit dem traum in weiß weg ein neues
kleid können sich die beiden übrigens
auch nicht einfach so leisten also in
diese geschichte kann man sich glaube
ich ganz gut rein fühlen und mario und
susanne sind uns jetzt auch live
zugeschaltet hallo ihr beiden schon dass
die zeit für uns habt ja kleiner
alptraum den ihr zweiter erlebt wie
geht's euch und vor allem susanne für
sie war der moment als sie gemerkt haben
das ist nicht mein kleid
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich war
total im schock als mein mann mir die
fotos geschickt hat nicht gesehen aber
das wort gar nicht mein kleid war ich
dachte mein puls gefühlt auf 200 und ich
hab nur gesagt vater sofort hin es ist
nicht mein kleid und ich war einfach
einen schock was ich immer noch bin
weil bald steht die hochzeit an und mein
kleid ist nicht da ich denke dass das
überhaupt was einem passieren kann
wie gesagt ich glaube viele frauen
können sich ganz gut in ihre situation
rein fühlen was meinen sie
könnte es sein dass dieses dass ihr
kleid wieder gefunden wird wie ist ihre
hoffnung also die hoffnung gibt man ja
nie aus ich denke ich bete eigentlich
jeden tag und gucke auf dem handy dass
sich jemand meldet und sagt ihr kleid
ist wieder da nur die zeit gegeben immer
knapper und ich werde immer eine böse
ja aber wie gesagt die hoffnung gibt man
ja nicht auf was machen sie jetzt wenn
das kleid nicht auftaucht wird trotzdem
geheiratet
wir denken schon dass geheiratet wird
nur müssen wir gucken in welcher form
und die das noch machen es ist ja noch
ein bisschen zeit wir hoffen dass sich
alles noch gut er gibt alles
also macht das kleid wirklich so viel
für sie aus ja wenn sie dieses kleid
nicht haben ihr kleid dann wird die
hochzeit anders aussehen
ja wir sind ja so ein bisschen
traditionelles mussten bereits
geheiratet werden ich denke man anderes
kleid wird auch tun aber es wäre am
schönsten wenn unsere zeit also ihr
kleid wieder auftaucht
aber wir machen das beste draus okay das
wünschen wir ihnen so optisch gesehen
jetzt ich sie zum ersten mal sie sind
auf jeden fall so ein super pärchen und
deshalb alles gute und trotzdem das
schöne hochzeit egal ob mit kleid oder
anderen kleid dankeschön abend dann die
chips